all right
hello everybody and so
kind of not well well set up here
give me a second
sorry all right so i see
i've got brad is there sweet
let's see who else shows up what do you
got
43 people all right we got people in the
in the chat so welcome to the april
uh q a it is holy week um
and so here we are this holy week is
very strange
with covet and everything my own parish
is struggling
uh just to celebrate
we're we're struggling so i'm actually
going to be going to two different
parishes during holy week to be able to
do
to do the different services but you
know
that's how it is this this this lent has
anybody who follows me on twitter
will know that this lent has been uh not
the best lent
you know you can tell how i'm doing just
by social media
if i'm being if i'm like posting cocky
stuff
and being a jerk on social media it
usually means that i'm not doing very
well
so you know all right so
a few things before before we start
last month um first thing is last month
i
uh raffled off some a few things and i
didn't send them yet
and so i said that if i haven't send
them yet i'm not gonna raffle off
uh two more t-shirts two more shirts
until i send them and so
i should be able to send them soon i
just haven't but uh the emails are out
and so the people uh so i will send them
soon so sorry to those people
who won last month and have been waiting
uh to be
contacted by me yeah like i said this
whole month
but that's okay all right um and uh so
what's the other thing yes the other
thing is that last month i totally
forgot subscribe star
in terms of the questions and so i will
be starting with subscribe star this
this month to compensate for that
and so yeah
all right so we will get through this is
there anything else i need to
to uh announce i don't know
all right so i will start with subscribe
star
okay so from the last month
uh x oh so the way it works sorry for
people who are the first time
in the q a the way it works is that uh
if um
for people who are supporting me on
patreon for like 10
or more you get to ask questions in
advance and
so all these are the questions i'm going
to go through and then at the end i will
go through the super chats
and answer those questions and so i
usually do have time to get through
everything
it's hard for me to pay attention to the
chat because usually
even just answering the the the
questions from
uh from the different platforms it ends
up being like two hours long so
so yeah so if you want so so yeah so
i mean i am trying to do some surprise
streams once in a while now if you
notice
some carving streams i'll do i will do
more and so then in those
those kind of surprise uh streams it's
easier to ask questions and
i can pay attention to the chat more
because it's more kind of improvised
so pay attention to those if you want
but i can't tell you when they're going
to be because i don't know when they're
going to be
all right so here we go with subscribe
star from last month
so xrd asks
would you say there's a connection
between vegans and cain in their seeming
unwillingness to make the right
sacrifices
i don't want to pick on vegans but after
seeing recent stories of parents who
force veganism on their children
now these kids end up severely severely
malnourished some even dying
by the time authorities get to them i've
begun wondering where veganism fits in
all of this
so it's one of those
interesting things that so at least like
vegetarianism
let's say monks are vegetarian so monks
orthodox monks don't eat meat in theory
you know i'm sure in practice it happens
once in a while but
in theory they don't eat meat um and
also there's a there's a notion in
scripture that people didn't eat
meat before the fall not just before the
fall but actually they weren't supposed
to eat meat before the flood
and uh and that's why after the flood it
says that god gave permission
that people eat meat with um
without the blood so you had to bleed
the animal in order to eat it
and uh so there's a sense in which
eating animals is a kind of
condescension of the fall
on one hand um but on the other hand
there's also something about it which
how can i say this it's kind of like you
have to not see it necessarily as good
or bad but
you do have to see it as
as a kind of condescension of the fall
and so i i think that eating meat is
fine i don't think that there's anything
wrong with it
um but i think there's all and just like
i also think that
it's okay for soldiers to go to war and
to um
and to fight off enemies in terms of
when you know when a country's being
attacked by
foreign invaders but i think that all of
these things are kind of
condescensions to the fall let's say um
and so but it's not the same as veganism
because i don't think in scripture
there's any sense that people were vegan
rather just vegetarian and so because
even in the story of cain and abel it
would be very odd to think
they weren't supposed to eat meat and so
in theory abel didn't eat meat
according to the story but he still had
animals and so what were their animals
for if he's not going to eat their meat
and so
milk cheese uh like i don't know
wool so so they did use animals just
just not in the story they did use
animals just not
eat the meat so yeah
all right so that was the only question
on subscribe star
in march so let's go to see
if there are any questions so there are
no questions in april
uh that okay so you know what there is
one
i'm gonna be very i'll be i'll be nice
um
so big lasagna on subscribe sir ask i've
noticed that the more i learned about
symbolism the more
my humor got better i've read some
articles that
people 100 years ago laughed laughed
about 50 minutes a day nowadays
it's about five minutes does this make
sense to you um
i don't know i mean i think that i
i do think that there was definitely in
traditional societies there was
definitely just more joy in general
we have this weird image like in movies
and stuff about
these dark traditional societies but in
reality
because they were together because they
would they would just spend all their
time together
they would probably you're right they
probably would laugh more because they
were just together
you know it's if you're alone you don't
laugh
unless you're you're watching some funny
move but even then like
you wouldn't laugh out loud as much as
you would when you're with people and
you're kind of
with friends and stuff so it's possible
but it's good to have a sense of humor
if you understand symbolism because if
not it can actually take you to a very
dark place
so you know you guys know that i laugh
all the time for bad reasons but
probably good it's probably good for me
all right man i'm in a weird mood this
is this this might not go well
i hope it'll be okay all right so let's
move on
to uh to the symbolic world website
i just remind you guys as you know uh
the symbolic website is being redone
right now and so i'm working
actually even redoing the logos and just
the whole
the whole aspect of it and how it's
going to integrate the different things
that
i'm working on but not just me also all
the other people involved in the
symbolic world
so that's coming soon we will also have
a platform for discussion there because
right now the facebook group is still
hanging on but we all feel
like it's just a question of time before
even the facebook
group gets shut down because some of the
posts are getting shut down and so
just a question of time yeah all right
all right so c s c s
street soul or c streets will ask can
you explore the symbolism
in the story of samson you mentioned him
moving the doorway to a hill
and there is the lion and hundy event as
well
is he a nephilim uh no he's not a
nephilim
he's a he's definitely his symbolism is
related to
symbolism of nephilim in the sense that
because he
is a he's an israelite who is attracted
to foreign women
who who wants who has relations with
foreign women then there is
a there is a relationship with the idea
of nephilim or this idea of like
the people higher up on the mountain
going down the mountain to get potential
from that which is impure or that which
is not in your
level of identity um and uh
and so that's what that's that's what
happens in the genesis story but from
angels to
to men but you can understand it at
different levels right so
the though the uh
the different warnings that for example
uh are given
by solomon about going to the strange
woman and
he says the strange woman's foot the
strange woman the feet of the strange
women goes down into shale
so her feet go down into hell
and so this is this idea of like the
this idea of the
that which you don't know being kind of
on another plane is you
and b you have to be careful because it
it can you can waste your seed right
your seed could be lost in
in the darkness let's say so that is
one of the aspects of the symbolism of
samson but there's also a mystery
which is that it's like how do you flip
that how do you make it total because
ultimately we believe that god is the
god of all things and so how does that
turn like there's a reality to the to
the to the symbol
to the structure but then there's also a
way in which even
that aspect or the strange has to be
saved and that's what
christ that's what happens with christ
because christ
the the story of christ with the
samaritan is all about that
the story of christ with samaritan is
all about christ
going towards the strange woman and
marrying the strange woman you know
um and uh and that's why like i i said
many times that's why christ marries
rome that's why christ
saves rome because he is in a way
he is
he's let's say he's marrying the
daughters of cain
like he's marrying cain he's doing he's
rome is kane romans are the descendants
of cain
in terms of what they mean and so
there's this there's an aspect of the
symbolism of christ which resembles
the symbolism of the nephilim just like
this idea that
one of the interpretations of the the
symbolism of the nephilim is that the
the the daughters of uh of
the the sons of seth married the
daughters of cain
well that's what christ is doing
christ is marrying the marrying cain
uh but he but he does it in a way that
isn't
that doesn't fall he's able to do it
without falling he's able to kind of
gather all of this strangeness into
himself and transform it you know so
it's not the same it's it's
it's almost like one of the aspects of
what christ is doing
is is is healing the rift
of the of the first chapters of genesis
like healing those different
those different riffs and those
different problems so all right two i
need to not spend too much time on each
question or else i'm never gonna get
through
all right
all right so josh the mover asked hello
jonathan a quick question of validity
uh after careful consideration prayer
i've elected to take
st john of damascus as my patron saint
when i'm baptized well congratulations
josh that's awesome
at some point i would like to commission
a diptych with saint
damascene on the left and the three
hands icon of the theotokos on the right
would this be considered a violation of
any
iconographical rules would it be more
correct i haven't commissioned that
separate icons
i've not seen a diptych with those icons
together before i don't want to be in
any way innovative
um so it's fine to have icons with
different saints
um and have them like in a line or have
them
related to each other you see that in
kind of what's called family icons that
people would commission
so that's fine the problem is mostly
you have to be careful when you have
make an icon of the mother of god you
don't want
because in a way she is kind of the
summit of
of sanctity in the human level
and so i'm not sure i've ever seen an
image where she is just kind of uh
facing another saint besides saint john
the foreigner or saint john
uh the the theologian so i'm not sure
i'd have to think about it i'd have to
think about it and also
i mean if you could just have them made
it's two different icons i mean it
wouldn't be that difficult to just have
the
two panels and then you can you can put
them up the way you want
um maybe that could just be an easy
solution to avoid
any confusion right so when the ones
asked hi jonathan
any advice on navigating the symbolic
worldview with kids especially a very
literal minded five-year-old
he loves folk tales myths bible stories
and we talk about the deep patterns in
them but he often returns to but this
but did this really happen is the hero
plays
character real um
i would say like especially for a
five-year-old like you should just tell
them the stories and not
interpret them like there's no point in
interpreting the stories for a
five-year-old
you just tell them the stories and then
don't you don't need to go any further
than that the interpretation will come
later
so if you just tell the stories and you
kind of rejoice in the stories
um at some point maybe you can avoid the
question of
you know did this really happen um
i would say for sure in terms of fairy
tales you can say that
you can it's easy then to say no that it
didn't really happen in
in this way that you you think um
in terms of scripture i would just
answer yes to all all the stories
and in terms of saints story that would
just also answer yes to all the stories
so that's how i would that's how i would
do it
so you could always answer it happen
once upon a time you could say you could
just answer that
all right
so adam says hey jonathan you seem to
have a grasp on how 2020 would go
and have predictions for 2021 so when
will jacob and issa meet yeah i can't
answer that one
when jacob and esau meet as for 2021
i mean it's pretty much
it's pretty much on route for
just being a continua a continuation of
the clampdown mode
and so that seems to be what's what's on
the menu
um just a continuation of last year i
think
and also just making it acceptable like
just
just making everybody just accept that
this is the new normal as they say or
this is the
inevitable yeah all right so numerous
asks is solomon they're prefiguring of
christ
joseph and king david have a lot of
relevance to the story of christ but
solomon also seems to be relevant too
i've noticed he appears to be an
eschatological figure where all the
rebellions are put down there's peace in
the land
the temple is built and he rules as the
wise king and all the nations of the
world come to honor him yes of course
exactly and i think you i don't even
have to answer
the song of songs is usually attributed
to him as well sounds like the eschaton
to me and so i think you're right uh you
don't i
almost don't have to answer i almost
don't have to answer your question
so he's a figure of christ in that you
could say that
that he is um
yeah definitely in terms of the idea of
peace and the idea of the temple and
also the idea of the
of the queen of sheba you know of his
relationship with
the the the ends of the earth you would
say you know like the queen of shiva
coming
coming to kind of ask questions of him
is something like the
wise men coming to worship christ and so
there's this idea that
that he connected to the ends of the
earth
all the all the characters in scripture
are configurations of christ
that one's actually an easier one some
of them are harder some of them are
like samson is a harder one in terms of
understanding how but they all
are all right so luca skovic asks um
in chapter 35 symbols of space and time
foundations
sown in scandal stone in my brother's
book the language of creation
your but your brother quotes the bible
with wisdom the lord founded the earth
with understanding he established the
heavens
later in the chapter he quotes with
wisdom a house is built with
understanding it is established with
knowledge
its rooms are filled
i'm struggling to understand what these
sentences mean
what do wisdom understanding and
knowledge
uh mean in this context um
i i'm not gonna answer that man because
it's like pretty much that you could say
that it
that kind of stuff is exactly what the
the the that's exactly what the book is
about well
a little thing you could understand for
example in terms of
um in terms of understanding the idea of
wisdom found in the earth and and
understanding establishing the heavens
you
need to under the this is one of the
things that you talk about all the time
is this
this this cross this cross thing
happened where
with wisdom from above he found the
earth below and then with
understanding from below he establishes
he creates a foundation
he he establishes a solid ground for the
heavens and so
just for example then understanding that
can help you understand
this this relationship between the
invisible and the visible how one of
them provides
form you know uh
for for that which is below and that
which is below provides
uh support support and let's say
making explicit of that which is above
and so maybe that's the
the best way to understand
that um so you can understand like
wisdom
and unders wisdom and understanding
and then knowledge as the union of the
two
that's probably the best way to
understand it
wisdom is like under it's like the seed
understanding
is is like the the the
the explicit aspect of it you know
and so the difference between the wisdom
of a car
like knowing what it's for and the
understanding of a car
how it works like in terms of the the
mechanisms of the car
and then with knowledge that's how you
you that's
you that's how you fill the car with
knowledge uh
you use the car so when you're using the
car you need to have this basic
notion of how the car works in terms of
what it's what it can do and what it can
do
the purpose of the car the pattern of
the car in terms of
its spiritual purpose and reason and
then you can
then you can use the car um so i hope
that makes
i hope that helpful this stuff is it's
hard to talk about i also don't want to
put words in my brother's mouth
but uh that's how i would understand it
all right
okay so david flores asked with the
human animal hybrid news coming out
i can't help but see the human animal
gods of egypt and other cultures you
have already mentioned that ai
has patterns of an idol if ai is an auto
made of
of gold and silver what does the human
animal hybrid idol of flesh and bone
mean
is it the same as centaurs or something
entirely different
it's very close the idea of the animal
human
hybrid
is very close to the the centaurs and
the satires
in in ancient mythological thinking
a really good way to understand what
human animal hybrids are
so they're like in a basing of humanity
right
and you can see that even in terms of
the ethical problems that people are
seeing with uh
with uh this hybridization of this
making of chimeras they understand that
there's a danger of creating a lower
caste
of humans and so
of of of a human that is more basic that
is more
flesh you would say in terms of
spiritual understanding and so that's
what these hybrids are
and even in mythological thinking so the
centaur for example like in
in greek myth and in roman stories the
centaur is
constantly trying to like rape women
he's constantly trying to like
steal like the all the stories of the
centaurs like stealing
um hercules's wife there's this
mat there's this big story about how
centaur
says he's going to cross think so if you
know the story of saint christopher you
can see it's related actually
so so hercules is on one side of a river
and he has
the centaur comes and says i will carry
your wife across the river for you
and so this beast like a boat like a
like a
support is is capable of carrying
like an ark you could say is able to
carry the
the hercules wife across the river but
now
different from let's say saint
christopher different from the ark with
the antly animals in it
when the centaur comes to the other side
he's like gonna run away with her
and he's going to going to take her take
her with him
and so she's going to be lost you could
say and so the story usually has it that
hercules shoots an
arrow so you can see like the the kind
of the masculine or the order
reaffirming itself he shoots an arrow
across and then he kills the centaur in
order to be able to get his wife back
um so you can see how these stories like
these patterns they
they uh they play out in different ways
it's the same pattern but it just plays
out in different ways
um so uh so so that's mostly the way to
understand the problem of the
animal human hybrid is that it's kind of
a lowering
of of humanity
in um of the in terms of the human like
the human animal gods of egypt it's more
about
totemizing so it's more more about um
seeing seeing the things in the world
and how their patterns manifest certain
realities and then kind of elevating
that
in its pattern form and so you know
so it's kind of like i mean you could
say something like
you know the god of rain so rain is a
natural phenomena but the
but it has a pattern it has patterns it
comes and goes in certain patterns and
so
you can totemize that and then have a
god of rain and
but you can do the same with animals and
so certain characteristics of animals
will manifest certain realities and then
and then that's how you get these animal
human hybrids
um so so it's probably the best way to
understand
that and a good like it and that's a
negative version but there's a positive
version which is
the tetramorph right in the tetramorph
you have
also these animals that are brought up
into their pattern
and they kind of manifest different
aspects of divinity
in in the in the tetramorph so you don't
worship the tetramorph you don't you
don't sacrifice to the
to the to the cherubs but the the
the type of symbolism that they're
engaging with is similar to the
symbolism that
will give you these uh these kind of
gods with animal heads okay but like i
said it's not the same you don't worship
them
um but it's similar in terms of
in terms of what it's what it's doing
with uh with the
with the images of the animals
all right and so arosa 77 says this is a
question about contextualizing the
christian message
in missions to non-christian people
coming from a low church protestant
tradition
i'm increasingly appreciative of big t
tradition it seems to me that tradition
is the product of contextualized and
gospel originality
a message revealed within the
interaction of semitic and hellenistic
worlds in palestine to other ancient
cultures
contemporary especially protestant
missions values contextualization
efforts that include attempts
to shed as much cultural baggage of the
missionary before engaging
in the target mission culture and this
will almost be necessary
lead to a shedding of tradition what are
the losses when christians missionaries
plant new churches
without a reference to ancient tradition
be it in liturgy history devotional
practice
for the lady etc um
and so i mean
there's a there's a difficulty of course
in losing
it's a it's a game like it definitely is
a difficult game to play
uh and it's also one that honestly
usually will just play out
in a long term and that's that's one of
the things we struggle
because we don't have the patience uh
anymore to deal with a kind of a
long-term story
um so for sure in terms of the idea of
stripping down
the traditions you you have to be
careful because
you know christ embodies himself in
things like he embodies himself in
in particulars and so if you try to just
remove them
you can end up with something which is
not really christianity
um but it's uh but like i said it's a
tricky game
like you'd say you can look at the way
it happened in like russia and bulgaria
and how the orthodox evangelize
different peoples is that at first
probably the orthodoxy in russia
they translated into their language um
and it does seem like like
for example they let happen certain
things like
certain analogies people saw
between their ancient gods and
and the new characters like the saints
and with christ
and so they weren't afraid of saying of
of
helping people see through their own
tradition you know what it is that
that christianity was talking about you
know um
so that seems to have happened also like
in terms of evangelizing the northern
people
um there's a danger there too which is
you can also kind of misstep
and then end up with weird uh kind of
syncretism but
yeah i'm happy that i don't have to make
a lot of those decisions because it must
be very difficult to kind of find that
balance
all right so so alphonse asks
dear mr pedro my question maybe would be
are we in the start
or middle of a new wave of gnosticism
narcissism is like christianity on
mushrooms dog metzger
yeah so what's going on in this coming
age of aquarius i don't know yeah
joe dmt rogan on meditating
sam harris who also documented his
mushroom trip is orgism
another form of trying to get redemption
and salvation through certain kinds of
rules
and behaviors and rituals would you like
would you like to elaborate your
thoughts on narcissism
the critic of the church fathers and how
to avoid the mix-up of symbolism with
certain gnostic ideas
like ig the truth of the existence
angels demons heavens
and so on so the biggest problem with
narcissism is it is really one
big problem and most of the most of the
lower problems
emanate from emanate i use that word
it's hilarious talking about narcissism
like the the lower problems will be
connected to the higher problem and the
higher problem of narcissism is mostly
the idea
that uh that
the lowest god created the world and
that the world itself
is is a kind of is fallen
in its in its very origin and that
the the the supreme let's say
uh the infinite or the you know the the
the highest infinite principle does not
have any contact at all
with anything below him it's like this
completely self
self um you know self looking
self monad it's a monad right and so
christianity doesn't present a monad as
the infinite but
a trinity and so already in the infinite
there's the sense in which multiplicity
and and a certain dynamism is part of
infinity itself
um and that avoids a lot of problems and
so
so so then so narcissism always ends up
being some kind of idea that
that the world itself is fallen and so
you need
to be able through different to
different
acts of meaning through to rituals but
rituals as like keys
as these like secret keys that you can
that you can unlock doors and then
ascend
this hierarchy of heaven in order to to
free yourself from this corrupt world
and corrupt body
and that is not at all what christianity
is
uh christianity is about embodiment and
about incarnation
and although it does it does is suspect
to
people who are slave to their passions
or a slave to their bodies
it it's clear from the very beginning
that christianity is not against
uh the body and is and its rituals are
not
there to to uh make you escape
from reality but is there to integrate
reality
and to participate in the fullest sense
in in reality so if you look at
the the orthodox uh communion in the
orthodox liturgy you'll see
there are references to angels all
through the liturgy
and it talks for example it talks about
uh
christ being carried by the by the
orders of angels
down into the communion and so there is
this sense that there is this descent
but there's also
other places where it talks about we who
represent the cherubim like we who
are part are becoming analogous to the
angels
in our at our level and participating in
this giant
pattern and so and so there is in a
sense that we
that we have initiation rituals in order
to escape the world
but rather to to kind of have a full
experience of what creation is uh
so that's probably the best way that i
could talk about that
all right it's from mikael so what is
your opinion on abstract icons
malevich treated his black square as a
sort of icon
he kept hanging it high in a room's
corner as if it were an orthodox
artifact
nowadays the image is practically
treated as an icon of art as if art was
a spiritual being to be worshipped
recently i saw an exhibition of modern
semi-abstract orthodox art some of them
were really moving in a good way could
would
you could say that traditional icons are
an abstract art anyway
so it depends so this is this is a great
discussion that's happening right now
in let's say in orthodoxy so you could
actually see that malevich
is black's square his supremacist icon
is is something of narcissism like
there's something about
the desire to reduce the world to just
patterns and so it's like hey i'm for
patterns right i love patterns that's
what i talk about all the time
but the patterns have to be embodied
they're not you don't have
access i mean you can you can have
access to the pure pattern but it always
manifests itself in an embodied form and
so abstract art
is is there's something about it which
is dehumanizing and something about it
which is
alienating to the to the human person um
and so let's say
one of the tendencies in modern in in
the modern times has been to
s because some of the abstract artists
this is a complicated question but some
of the abstract artists especially
uh maurice denis who was who is a modern
kind of
modern catholic artist um and they was
part of this kind of weird modern
catholic revival of art he saw
him and not just him but other theorists
saw um
icons as being the root in terms of
abstraction
towards uh modern abstract art
but i think that that's a problematic
understanding
because
you could say in a way that traditional
icons are less
fleshy than renaissance uh art
less uh less kind of passionate than
baroque art let's say um but to say that
the the the orthodox icon is more
abstract
is to to act as if the fleshiness of
baroque art and of kind of uh
romanticism or academic art is more real
is more embodied and that's not right
you know that embodiment doesn't mean
the fleshy passions right there is a
there's a kind of a there's a balance in
the in the christian body you would say
and i think that the icons try to
manifest that balance that sober balance
you could say of the body
um so that's what i think
what time is it 9 30 all right um so
nelson justin evan
asked how should an orthodox christian
rightly order their finances
how are you asking me questions like
that do you have any big picture
suggestions about how to handle money in
a spiritually responsible way
example how to plan retirement without
credit interest
can luxury purchases be justified man
you guys
this is not you should ask your priests
a question like that um
i mean i think that i think that you
have to like i can just tell you the way
that i've i
i've done it and my wife and i have
always done it is we
we've always just been very grateful for
whatever it is that we have and we've
been
very poor and we've also
been more fortunate in certain times and
so
so we just we just go at it
one step at a time and uh to be honest i
don't
have investments and uh and i'm not
saying that that's the way to go i'm not
saying that that's the way to do things
but
it's both of us both my wife and i
have a sense that that's not the best
thing you can do with your money
uh is like invest of course if you're
just going to squander it then that's
not better but it
i think there yeah
i think that it it's i don't think
there's one way to go about it i think
that uh
you just have to be attentive to
the way that that god kind of presents
this this possibility to you in your
life and uh
be attentive to what's going on around
you to the questions around you to the
needs around you and
um and just act
and just act based on that but i don't
i'm not against investment and i'm not
like i don't think it's wrong
i also like the idea of luxury purchases
is a complicated one because it's very
it's a relative thing um all right okay
so blank asks okay blank so how do you
do
could you discuss the symbolism of the
two witnesses in revelation
how to understand them in terms of the
end of the world specifically the end of
the world we're in
i've heard in protestant circles that
they are related to john the baptist
elijah and enoch
do you think this is accurate or no i
think that
that attribution to john the baptist
elijah enoch is a pretty universal one
i don't think that it's come i think
that it comes from the church father i
don't remember exactly who but i think
it's a very ancient understanding
of um of the witnesses
um and i mean it has to do with the idea
of those which were taken
up uh those that were taken up without
dying
and so that's mostly the idea of the
you know there's a there's a pattern
that
kind of at the end of a world there are
the there are these characters that are
taken up
and then before a change it's like uh
it's kind of like the at the end things
kind of separate and there's a moment of
transition and
there are certain elements which go up
let's say and
that's what enoch is that's also what
elijah is
that's why they're in the elijah story
there's
the enoch story there's the flood and
then in the elijah story
there's also the the crossing of the the
the river with the garments of skin and
so
that's trying to show you that this is a
transition
that then uh elisha is going to
start a new world and elisha's starting
in the world there's a lot of
his miracles that are there to show you
that he's starting a new world like
raising the axe head and
you know there are these different
miracles that are there to show that
and moses is the same too right so moses
dies but his body is taken up
so so yeah that's usually the way that
it's understood
and so the idea is that
you could say that these witnesses will
appear at the end before the end of the
world
and so so there's a sense like you could
understand it like uh
you could understand it the way that
christ said of john the baptist that he
is the elijah
that will come so you can understand
that before the end
there will be a elijah that will come
there will be an enoch there will be uh
you know another
john the baptist that will that will
manifest before
before the end so
all right
so krista asks what is your experience
with tarot cards
and do you think it is okay for
christians to use them for symbolic
purposes
i don't really have any experience with
tarot cards i i would say it's probably
it's probably best to avoid them like to
especially avoid people who are
are using them because they really
people do use them as a kind of weird
uh like a kind of weird divination
and there is warnings in scripture
against divination and the tradition
against that type of action you know
it's
you can understand why it's dangerous to
to want to devise your future
or to want to use pattern understanding
as a way
to give yourself power towards your
future
um and so that's a dangerous game to
play and the thing about it is that it
it's it's probably not completely
hogwash which is why
it's dangerous to to play with those
games
um so if you want to if you want to kind
of just look at
tarot cards and try to understand
because they're certainly using uh
they're certainly using some some
patterns
that are that are connected to something
like they're not
they're not arbitrary um but i would say
just to be careful because it's not
it's a it's a dangerous road to to get
on
all right so vsac282008 says hi jonathan
i've been reflected on the surgical
circumvent
circumvolutions they seem to define
sacred space
great in sensation at the beginning of
liturgies established center
sensing singing transformed the world
so these different cycles of sensing and
symbolize sacred transformations
the direction does not seem arbitrary
sometimes clockwise sometimes
counterclockwise could it have something
to do with symbolism of the right and
left
or could it refer to cosmic symbolism
sun wise connection
or even interplay of both i you know
i'll be totally honest with you
i've been thinking about that a long
time in terms of
how it works in the liturgy and the the
how the processions work in the liturgy
and also
they're like i think your intuition is
is very good in
the sense that there seems to be in the
way that the christian church is set up
an interplay between two symbolisms one
is
left and right hand and then the other
is north south
east west um and so the
left side so if you're in a church and
you're facing east
right the left side is north so the left
side
is dark and the right side
is south and so this the right side is
light
um and so there seems to be
something of that in the way that even
you can if you look at
medieval churches the way that they
would decorate the churches they they
definitely were taking that into account
and so the
northern transept would often be like
the dark transept and so they would
have weird symbolisms in the northern
transit for example it uh i think it's
in
i think it's in the not sure which one
they
they have all the weird stories in the
northern transit they have all the
foreigners
all the all the strangers in the old
testament they have the
the story of the ox cart with the golden
hemorrhoids
all the weirdness like all that kind of
uh that kind of loose symbolism of
something which is kind of loose and not
attached to uh to the to the center the
the
righteous the righteous strangers you
would say you know and
all these other kind of strange stories
um
and then and in the south side then
there'll be more like new testament
stuff and everything
so they they're definitely something
about that in terms of
and so the idea of like coming out in
the north like
that the origin of the sun even the
origin of the sun is in the north
like that's something that's hard for
people to understand the sun comes up in
the east but
it's like the seed of the sun is down in
darkness right it's hidden in the
darkness and so
the idea that the origin is in the north
but it reveals itself in the east
right and so you can see that how that
would be like this this
this kind of procession from north
but it doesn't totally like it doesn't
completely jive to me so i probably
shouldn't be talking about that
um but it's something i'm still thinking
about i've been thinking about for
20 years or whatever um
all right so timothy aspeslaw says hey
jonathan what is a good way to help
someone understand or experience what
renegade calls super rational um
i mean that's what we when we talk about
the news that's what we're talking about
it's the idea of direct intuition um
and so it's you experience that all the
time like you experience super rational
all the time it's just that we're not
used to
having we're not used to understanding
those experiences every time you
every time you experience unity in
anything you're experiencing something
which is super rational
in the sense that the rational can
analyze the parts but it can never jump
to the unity
and so unity is always super rational
but then once you have the unities
then you can do it again right so it's
like you can analyze the parts of the
chair
and then you jump up to the chair and
then once you have chairs and other
things you can analyze those
then jump up to higher categories and so
that's what it is and so
imagine that like in yourself where you
have all your thoughts and you have all
your passions and all your desires and
all your
and all your multiple personalities and
all of that and then once in a while you
can have this glimpse of
something which unites it all together
and it's beyond thought and it's beyond
it's like a direct experience uh you
know it's it's it's beyond
analyzing it it's so that's probably the
best way to understand it
is to see how we actually experience
that
we actually experience that quite a bit
like we just don't recognize it
so
all right all right so i'm moving now on
to
to um patreon
and uh getting a uh a little glance at
the chat i'm happy to see that
neil from dirk robbins is there sweet
and symbolic
memes is there always funny stuff
lisa's there cool all right
so yeah look happy to see everybody in
there
thiago is there nice i did was on your
channel
look at me going through the chat i'm
becoming a real youtuber
after four years of doing this
all right and so dirt for robin says
symbolic memes are the best yeah the
the the memes are are hilarious
oh they always they also work on on like
often work on like several levels and
i'm like man
he's really thinking this stuff out
okay so let's go let's go into patreon
all right so jason
and we're all curious about who symbolic
memes is
one day we will discover who you are
it's to happen
all right so jason
he says symbolic means i don't make them
they just manifest themselves that's
hilarious
all right so jason gattawaltz says
uh how would you describe virgil in the
comedy
human reason a poet uh
i think that i think that at least
especially in the uh in the comedy
virgil is playing several roles for
dante on the one hand he's playing
he's playing the role of that which
inspired dante and so it's it's a it
starts out
as a personal at a personal sense it's
that
he is the one that is like dante's
mentor you could say um and so
and so in that in that sense but
his mentor you would say twist up to a
certain level
and so yes he does also represent
something like
reason and also something like
for at least for dante definitely
represents the poet and so because
so you have to understand that
so virgil is the is is
uh dante's inspiration
but he's he's really is his inspiration
so not just personally
but in the sense that the descent into
the underworld uh
mean like the descendant of the
underworld uh structure
is in the aeneid right
it's part of the aeneid and it's part of
the writings of
of virgil so you can imagine that virgil
would have homer you know kind of
guiding him along
and so dante sees himself as as a as
just like dante is taking virgil's
notion of the descendant of the
underworld
and then joining that with
christianity okay so that's what that's
what he's doing
and so that's
that's what's happening in the in the
story it's like
that's that's how that's also what's
happening as virgil
guides dante up this fee of the up the
levels and then at some point
has to stop and then dante moves up
higher and
you know has ends up with a a saint
ends up um with uh
now i can't remember his name that's
horrible
who guides dante up the guy who wrote
who who's like wrote the templar chart
for the templars like i know i know who
he is i just can't remember
oh that's horrible it's horrible that
he's not that his name isn't coming to
me
um all right will we continue so that's
what so i think that's what that's what
it is
um it's gonna come to me
and then i'm gonna i'm gonna feel really
stupid all right
so norm grande says
i'm not sure how prevalent the seven
last words of christ are for orthodox
but these
words as christ's last sermon placed
under the themes of forgiveness father
forgive them
uh salvation today you will be with me
relationship
um okay so he goes through all the seven
way heavily in the catholic faith i
wonder what sort of symbolic story arc
you might see there perhaps a summation
of his ministry
covenant fulfillment or even as a resume
of the christian story as a whole
i'd have to think about it to be honest
i've never thought about
the the the last words of christ as a as
an arc or as a story
so i'd have to think about it it's it's
definitely something which sounds
plausible
at the at the outset so i would
definitely have to think about it more
all right um so conor mitchell says why
does russia hold
um almost a mythical boogeyman role in
western society
or at least in the american mindset um
i mean because you need one i guess they
realize that they need one they tried to
get rid of
their boogeyman and then they realize
that they that they
that they kind of need it and so we went
back to it
the funniest thing about the russia u.s
story
there really is like a wisdom in
understanding what happened in terms of
how
how how things happened and so
so you can think about it like in terms
of christianity let's say so you could
think about how
let's say after the revolution
you know especially let's say after
world war ii during the cold war
the u.s were sending missionaries they
would send people with like that would
smuggle bibles and would try to like
inject uh christian christianity into
into russia and then so there was like
the secret action
the secret seeds that were being planted
in russia people bringing bibles and
trying to pray praying for russia
praying for the salvation of russia
like this massive kind of attention and
movement
from christianity in into this dark
place that russia was
and russia was doing the same right
russia was sending their spies over to
the u.s
infiltrating culture you know uh trying
to affect
popular characters and uh and let's say
you have these these um theorists that
communist theorists that end up becoming
very popular in
in the u.s institutions and kind of
infiltrating
u.s institutions this whole idea of the
long walk
to the institutions so you have the
secret action on the
from the russians on the americans then
you have the secret action from the
americans on the russians
and then th this like this secret seed
grows up and it makes it that they flip
they like switch over and so all of a
sudden
america becomes this like secular
you know wasteland and russia becomes
this like new bastion of christianity
i mean think about it how crazy that is
like how just
nuts that that is that that happened in
our lives that we saw that
flip happen completely
it's nuts and so but it can help you
understand how
reality works how it's like these secret
seeds that we're planting
you know it's like even now like let's
say this work that we're doing i talked
about this recently with
paul vander clay um this idea that the
work that we're doing now let's say what
you guys are doing with me and and the
symbolic world people and
it's like we're not getting massive
attention and it's probably better we're
not
uh there's a sense in which the work
we're doing of like
re-enchanting the world or helping
people see
the re-enchantment of the world is like
this secret work that's happening
and it's gonna grow like it's it's gonna
grow because it is
right it is the end of the of the cycle
of
of uh of the day of of like
disenchantment and so it's gonna it's
gonna happen
and and i think like i i really do
believe that that in 10 years or
whatever
so a lot of people are going to start to
think symbolically and not even know
where it comes from
they don't even know they they don't
have to it doesn't matter but it'll have
grown up and it'll have
had its its fruit so it's an interesting
uh
it's an interesting interesting
way to understand how the world works
sorry i didn't totally answer your
question but i think i
i did in a way
all right so paul dumas says hi jonathan
you have mentioned that we should
not read too much into dreams is it
because they are by nature unreliable or
only because
the vast majority of us lack the
discernment to analyze them
by extension do you think that all
modern psychological theorizing about
the meaning of dreams
freud jungyeon is worthless thank you
for your work
so so the reason why you don't want to
pay too much attention
to dreams is that it's it's kind of like
so dreams in the in this in terms of
consciousness there's something like the
the waters of chaos and so consciousness
arises out of this this water of
consciousness
um and then goes back into it so it's
like this cycle
of awake and sleep it's the cycle of of
life and death it's the cycle of work
and sabbath right it's the cycle of
light and dark so
the the the sleep is like a little flood
and i think if you read matthew's book
you'll see that
he talks about that um and so
most of dreams are just like chaos
they're just like they're just chaotic
and they
and you shouldn't you shouldn't give too
much attention
to that and i don't know like maybe it's
just me but
i know some people that that pay a lot
of attention to their dreams and
there's something unhealthy about that
they end up being
it's almost like they're living in their
dreams it's like they're
they're they're living in their dreams
rather than living in the in the real
world when you're not careful
um but the thing about that is so you
can understand the best way to
understand is like it's like the
on the water the lower waters okay and
so
these lower waters are like these waves
in this chaos and this kind of
bubbly stuff but the lower waters are
also the place of like a mirror you
could say
and so if the waters are still let's say
then once in a while they can become
a mirror for higher things um
and so that's why people do have real
visions
in dreams and so they do have
uh true revelations and dreams you see
it in scripture you see it in the
tradition you see it all over the place
that this happens um but most of the
time
because we're not saints because we're
not most of us don't live in prayer with
still minds
most of our dreams are just a mess of
chaos and of
desires that are crossing each other and
contradictory things that don't make any
sense and so it's dangerous to
to to uh to pay too much attention to
that so
so yeah that's what i think and the
church fathers
they they really weren't people against
paying too much attention
to dreams um for those i think for
like for similar reasons because most of
the time it's just chaos
all right so
dom palermo says it is not what goes
into a man that defaults the body would
that which comes out porn images are not
inherently bad say in the hands of a
blind man
this simple frame can be used to assess
the question of
psychologically coarse dna treatments
i personally do not condone abortion
rolling up my sleeve is not
a symbolic moment for me the pope is
relevant i'm not i'm not sure where
you're going with this dude
um
the pope is irrelevant he's on my pope
individuals make choices and identifying
with the religious aspects of the meta
story or not it
is a choice i find this to be a
potentially mod
dangerous modern line of presupposition
how can we better show
that the participatory actions of the
individuals is not separate from the
movement
of the whole in material action and
invisible meaning
i'm not sure i'm sorry dom i don't
totally understand your question
and i think i'm so sorry about that
all right so michael mueller asks at
certain points
from premonitions or heartfelt prayer i
will be
struck in the back of the head a
shiverule down my spine
like there was a thought or idea that i
was too large to bring to realization
what is the meaning
of this from a phenomenological or
symbolic perspective is it related to
the snakes sliding down the tree
uh or bird too large to nest um
i mean i understand i don't know like in
terms of the the physio physiological
description but
you know i mean i think that we can
sometimes we do have these kind of
terrifying experiences of connecting to
to a reality that is bigger than us so i
think that's what you're describing so
i'm not sure though
if it has to do with um like a snake
sliding on the tree
but for sure there is there we do like
we i understand what you mean in the
sense of
suddenly being kind of overwhelmed by a
sense of
of almost like sacred terror and i think
it's
it's good like it's good that that
happens to us and we it's good if it can
help us to understand
how bigger the world is and what we're
able to perceive so
so that's probably good so ryan pinkham
says have you read saint john of
damascus on dragons and ghosts no i have
not
he seems to be talking about physical
animals beasts in terms of ghosts
really physical animals
i understand dragon symbolism but you
think they physically existed
it doesn't seem that crazy to me and so
of course dragons
existed i mean dragons probably exist
now
it's just it's just i'm just when i talk
about dragons have to
have to have an effect on the world or
else people wouldn't talk about them the
way they do
what i'm trying to help people
understand is that the dragon is
is a is a different type of category
than just the
the like regular type of categories that
we
that we use and so so you could
encounter a dragon
um but then someone else might encounter
a dragon it won't be the same dragon
it'll be like another phenomena that
will be a dragon so the dragon is like
is like is kind of like this
unknown monst this unknown being this
unknown animal unknown
terrifying unknown uh phenomena you know
and so so i think that people did
encounter dragons and i think people
especially encounter dragons when
they're in places they've never been
before and they
especially encounter dragons when
they're in like
new lands or in the you know in like in
the ins
out on the ocean you know steam sea
monsters and all that stuff that's where
you encounter
dragons when you're in places where
there are things that you don't know
you know there are things crawling
underneath
that you don't understand so i hope that
makes sense
uh so it's like i i don't think you
could ever dissect a dragon
and uh and uh and have like a zoological
category that you could
have dragon dna how about that to say
that i don't think dragons are like that
um but i do think you can encounter them
that's for sure
hope that makes sense to you
in reading the gospels on the passion i
was struck with the many
seemingly arbitrary events that occur in
these stories huh
uh could you imagine could you maybe go
into the meaning of christ not bearing
the cross
uh and simon of cyrene why isn't this
part of all the gospels
i mean the reason why it's not part of
all the gospels not is not as important
in understanding let's say the mystery
of that of that moment when
when a character from far away
carries the cross of christ for him
you know
it's it has to do again with with with
ro with like it has to do with something
something like christ is going to save
the foreigners christ is going to save
rome christ christ is going to say the
ethiopian eunuch
you know all these these far away
characters
that that this is actually this is
actually how it's going to play out
um at least that's how i understand it
so kevin patterson asks hi jonathan i
was touched by your story where priest
crossed himself upon seeing your icon
carving for the first time
i want to make such art which
participates in divine liturgy as your
visual arts do
though i struggle to accept the lower
place given to my proclivity towards
let's say
movement arts music cinema stage
performance while in pagan traditions
the shaman would be highly revered for
the same
role what is the highest form of these
arts
how can these skills participate in the
divine liturgy
i mean we have we have this
like we it's called i mean the priest is
moving
the priest is is uh is acting
and i like acting in a sense of of of
moving
in the space and moving in the church
we have processions which move around
the buildings and the
the the organization of those movements
is can be
very touching you know a good procession
a beautiful procession can be really
transforming
we don't we don't understand that
because we're so far from that
but a good a good procession can really
affect the world um
like there's a parish there's a catholic
parish in chicago that i went to
and uh and they totally understand that
like they they in chicago they
they uh they organize these uh these
processions like these massive
processions
huge with like everybody vested and and
incense and
you know these banners and uh and and
like maybe i don't know if they carry
statues and stuff but
you know you get in the orthodox
tradition they'll carry icons on banners
and they'll
carry holy objects and stuff and they
have these processions through space
and they kind of let's say they they
transform
space you know by by by
moving into it you know with this kind
of holy movement and so i think that
that's the highest
aspect of that
so yeah
so conor asked hello jonathan i've been
watching your videos for several months
now
and greatly enjoy your content i'm
reading through genesis
and the way that lot's daughters take
advantage of him really struck me
as odd this is just an example of how
depraved the city of sodom
had gotten or is there a deeper symbolic
interpretation that i'm missing
yeah there is a deeper symbolic
interpretation that you're missing
so this is the tough stuff guys this is
the tough symbolism
uh
yes so susan martin said saint john of
cancer in chicago
they're the ones who are doing these uh
these uh these great uh
um okay so
the the story of lot's daughter in
in that moment has to do with the end of
a world
and it has to do with
it has to do with the the the leverage
it's
it's it's using the same symbolism as
the leverid
so the with the leverage is the idea
that if
a man dies then the uh
then then his brother can give
a son to his wife to his widow
and so the the idea of taking your
brother's wife is completely immoral
like it's completely wrong
um and so in
in but in the end like in this
weird moment of end of the world
there's a there's a weird thing that
happens like there's this strange
type of symbolism um you see that in the
story of um
in the story of uh
ah what's your name why is it that my
brain isn't working tonight
when when joseph goes to egypt
and then uh
i can't remember the names of the
characters in the scripture what is
wrong with me
um there's a there there's there's
one of the sons of one of the sons of
jacob his his own son dies
and then the name is going to come back
to me i hope and uh and then he gives
and so his wife doesn't have a child and
so he says to his other son you need to
give
a child to his to this woman and but he
refuses to do so
and so he dies the sun
and then he it's like the other son and
then the other son dies too
and so this woman is like doesn't have a
son and so she actually ends up
she actually ends up like sleeping with
the the father
in order to get a son for herself from
her husband so this like that's the
that's the weird moment man that's the
strange that's the strange thing that
happens at the end of uh
of the world um and so it's not to say
it's not about it's not to say that what
lot's daughters did was
moral it wasn't um but it's just in the
story you see
you see this type of flip happen
like this this breakdown of meaning like
this breakdown of a coherence
um and that's what leverage symbolism is
about it's about this
this weird break in terms of normal
coherent
uh causality um and that's what
and it brings about you know
the resurrection so
yeah yeah so it's judah
it was on end exactly there you go you
guys you guys have got it and so onan
was the the but onan was the son that
didn't want to give a daughter
didn't want to give a child to judah's
uh step-daughter
judah's uh not step-daughter but
the daughter of his son his first son
yeah so onan ism so onanism is a is a
is actually a word for masturbation or
like
because it's wasting seed and so onan
didn't want to give
a son to his brother's wife and so
he wasted his seed and so soon not to
give her a son
um so yeah
so that's that's it sorry this is
getting weird
okay so let's keep going here
all right so wait where am i here
all right
so arie fisher says i asked verveiki on
his q a yesterday what he thought of
your assertion that reality
is more like a hierarchy of beings than
abstract platonic forms
he ended up spending half the q a
answering this question
i should listen to that uh so i'll do my
best to synthesize his answer
it says because there is a pluralism of
seeing the forms as either personal or
impersonal
across history and cultures reality is
deeply ambiguous suggesting that the two
conceptions are probably highlighting
different aspects of the same reality
because of similarity between our
personhood and the forms is not
technical because of the combinatorial
explosive amounts of similarities
between
any two identities but rather has to do
with its relevance to us
on what grounds can you legislate what
people should and shouldn't find
always relevant doing so would suggest
that you have found the answer
to end what has so far only been a
proliferation of pluralism
thus we should make sure thus we should
take an evolving relationship to the
sacred not a resolving one
i'm not sure i understand the second
part of that but i agree that in a way i
agree that there is uh
that there's a sense that that
that there's both and that there's a
relationship between both um
and you find some like resolution
of that in the idea of
let's say something like the virtues
right which are both
the virtues are most like they're like
embodied patterns that you
that you manifest but they're also
understood as angels and so you have
this
you have places where these kind of come
together
but you have the idea of patrons like
the idea of patrons means that
because we are persons
and we are the ones doing the relevant
realization
right so intelligence ends up infusing
into into that and so intelligence
scales up i'd love to i probably should
talk about it with
john that would be problem i've been
looking for for like a a
subject to talk about with him so maybe
that could be a good subject to talk
about with him
um
all right so romer asked hi jonathan and
congratulations on reaching
666 patrons that's odd it's an odd thing
to say
uh so what symbolism stories from the
bible do you find most puzzling
or impenetrable are there any chapters
that you would be especially interested
in discovering the meaning of
um i think still revelation is still
man that book and so it's like i i did
this one video
on revelation and i'm trying to write
the second
the second one and i'm like struggling
because there's so much it's like
as soon as you start talking about it
just splinters into a million directions
and so it's really tough and so i feel
like there are many chapters in
revelation that i don't totally
understand that i just don't get it's
it's just too dense it's so
dense it's like every word every
sentence is is like a little
world that you have to unpack and so
it's very difficult
i mean to be totally honest with you i i
feel like
i feel like the story of jesus is a
story that i don't understand still
there's there there are things in there
that are just
i mean i have these glimpses and
sometimes it's like i have glimpses and
then they
vanish really fast and they kind of go
away i can never really
i mean it's probably best that i can't
it's probably that's that that's part of
uh
but definitely like that story there are
also a lot of stories in judges which
i have like i have like inklings about
but some of them are just
so strange that it's hard to really
capture what's going on
um and so
like matt sierra said he was going to
write a book about the book of judges
and i was like yes
write a book about the book of judges
but i know if it's going to happen i
hope that would be awesome if you could
do that because
the book of judges is really hard to
understand some of them you can get and
then others you're like
this is obviously has meaning like this
obviously has meaning but
what's going on
all right so dear jonathan tom holland
points out in dominion that god boasts
to job about wrestling with leviathan
holland portrays this as a remnant of
early religions where such
stories were central what is your reply
why was it necessary
for god to wrestle with leviathan as
leviathan's creator
it's definitely not a it's definitely
not a
a remnant i mean you can say it's a
remnant but it's it
it follows all the way into the new
testament
you know uh when it says that
that god defeats the leviathan the great
satan and so
there's a sense it has to do i mean in
this sense it has to do with the idea of
god
as bringing order to chaos like that's
one of the aspects of light of the
divine logos of
you know and so you could say that the
idea like
i've mentioned this recently in a few
talks where this like strange image at
the end of
of revelation where it says that there's
no more ocean
right and so this image of the new
jerusalem and they said there's no more
ocean
so that's like also saying there's no
more leviathan like
those two things are very close and so
it's like leviathan has been defeated
chaos has been is gone it's all
the whole world is full of the glory of
god let's say
um and so that's what it's referring to
that's what it's culminating to at least
and so if if
if the source like the physical source
or like the
let's say the textual reference that is
used in scripture
comes from you know other traditions
that doesn't bother me one bit i mean
whatever that's fine with me but it's
still part of a puzzle that's moving
towards this final image you know of the
serpent being cast down
of the ocean being dried up and this
this chaos being finally completely um
being completely defeated so
hello jonathan i don't know if you've
answered this before but why is it
important
for the hair of medusas to be made of
snakes
um
i mean it's such a it's such a it's such
a it seems to me like it's such an
intuitive thing like it's such an
intuitive thing
in the sense that
right so hair is hair is like is the
covering hair is like
is also death you know hair is the dead
things it's like a dead covering that
you have on yourself
and so it's like doesn't it make sense
to you that
the the that the snake would be
like the hair in the sense that even
even if you just would like to mix
christianity and and hellenic uh myth
like
this that snake brings about death
brings about the cycle of death right he
changes the skins he lose he loses his
skin
and he and he and he changes all the
time and so like this
this change also the change like medusa
changes people to stone and so
she's an agent of transformation in a
dark sense
um and so that's what snakes are they're
you know they change
i hope that makes sense you know and and
it's like how do you
so how do you how do you stop the medusa
you
have you give her an identity like if
she sees herself
then she's she and then she's done it's
like she
so you know makes a lot of sense
so you freeze her the way you stop the
snakes and the dead
snake hair is you freeze her
all right i think that i i don't know
that's as close as i'm gonna get to that
one
uh so enrico says any thoughts on
symbolic meaning of us trying to become
a star-faring civilization
trying to reach the heavens or names of
the space x rockets etc
is it something positive like an
abrahamic call to look at the stars and
leave the father's house or more like a
tower of babel story
so the first thing to understand is that
the space is not the same as heavens
it's just not space has become
the ocean so the symbolism of
the ocean is the symbolism of space the
way we understand it now
going out into space and going where no
man has gone before
is a seafarer's story it's a it's it's
it's an explorer
story it's a you know it's like uh
it's like saint it's like alexander the
great going out into the strange lands
and so
that's what's that's what uh space
exploration is about
so it doesn't really it doesn't really
have to do with uh
with going into heaven in the
traditional sense um
but is it also a form of tower babel in
the sense that it isn't there is a
certain arrogance
because you're really going into death
like you're you know
uh i really don't think that we're ever
going to become a star-faring
civilization
because you i mean ever is a big word
but let's say
at least not in the on the foreseeable
horizon
it's as if you could it's it's like it's
like asking a whole civilization it's
like asking people to live
under the wall under the ocean for a
very long time
it's like technology can hold out chaos
to a certain extent but if you
go if you try to like live right in the
chaos like
all the time at some point the cracks
you can't avoid the little cracks
they're going to start to
the water is going to seep in you can't
so you can't live in space space is
death space is
absolute death it's it's the most
hostile place that exists
that you can think of it'd be like
living in like a you know like a
molten lava i mean you could do it but
it's not
you can't live like that forever so i
don't think that we could really become
a star-faring civilization
all right so jonathan was the meaning
behind not blessing the firstborn in
scripture when jacob crossed his hands
i came to remember you say that flips
occur at edge of categories is this the
transition
point in the story yeah that's a i've
talked about this before
that's a difficult um it's a difficult
text to interpret because you're not
sure which way it's going
and so you can understand that jacob so
jacob steals
the blessing from his father
uh and so there's a there's like this
this flip where
esau is supposed to get the blessing
jacob takes it from him
and so when he crosses so when so when
so when joseph who is jacob's favorite
son
comes to have his sons blessed the idea
that jacob
crosses his hands and so it's not clear
whether he
crosses his hands because he's trying to
reproduce the same pattern
and he's being tricky jacob tricky
tricky jacob again
or there's another tradition which is
that
that joseph out of respect presented
the children the other way around
you know out of respect for his father
knowing that his father was the second
born and got the blessing
and that then jacob crosses his hands to
restate to like restate
the right way and i'm not sure which one
it is
um so
so yeah it does have to do with this
flip between the left and the right for
sure that's
that's definitely what it has to do with
um and it has to do
ultimately with the problem of again the
problem of how
christ ends up blessing cain you know
the firstborn gets blessed again
um get rome gets blessed
because israel is the second born it's
always the second born israel is the
second born from the beginning
you know from from the time of abel
it's the whole mythological structure
around
israel is about the second the second
born and so
there's a sense in which there's a flip
that happens in christianity
um so jail says
sorry joe says i remember an episode of
the television show through the rock
where weird alien convict parodies a
parody song and it results in an earnest
patriotic country in western anthem
uh weird al becomes normal owl is humor
only ever subversive solely act solely
recreative
also since being baptized have managed
to retain to some extent a few cool cat
obscure secular type friends that have
noticed an increase in the mockery
of things that were originally mocker
themselves yeah
something irks me about the advent of
shrek memes and their ilk but i can't
put my finger on it every blessing i'm
not sure about what you mean in terms of
that but
for sure there is for sure there is
exactly
that like there is the idea of
irony kind of turning back on itself and
and you know it's
inevitable that'll happen that's kind of
this double flip that i talk about or
i talk about watch the fools in terms of
watching the fool kind of restate
the normal in the end that's definitely
what it's all about
um and so yeah that's maybe that is what
shrek is about like i've never really
thought i've never really thought about
it maybe the shrimp because shrek is the
ogre right shrek is the
is the weirdo is the is the excluded one
and so the idea of
like mocking shrek for being you know
the whole tip the fedora thing and the
that whole kind of aesthetic of the of
those shrek memes
um those were those were maybe having to
do with that
like a double weird kind of weird double
mocking i haven't thought about it so
much though
so drew mcmahon asked jonathan do you
have any thoughts on the veganism
movement that seems to be taking over
every restaurant and fast food place has
some beyond meat or impossible burger
option yeah
yeah the aesthetics of the vegan is
important to understand because there's
a transhuman
aspect to it like a weird technological
aspect to veganism it's strange you
wouldn't think it like you'd think that
veganism
would kind of have a kind of earthy
vegetable look like a
you know like a back to the earth type
aesthetic but it has a weird kind of
techno
you know technological food aspect of it
and so
even the even the term like impossible
burger is interesting
in terms of understanding the strange
extreme that it represents but
yeah it's it's it's definitely an odd
thing my feeling about it has something
to do with this weird
like it's not because i mentioned
earlier about how
the the monks are vegetarian and that
they also
live but i think that there's it's weird
the incarnation this veganism like this
especially the aggressive kind of
veganism um
but i'm not sure i need to think about
it more
so march mcluhan uh g garcia sorry i'm
not saying
i'm not i forget to tell you to mention
the names nathan hart says reading
dominion
i can't help but start to feel that the
temporal evolution of christianity is
deterministic and that even if
traditional christianity were to be
restored to its former
status the process would merely repeat
itself and we'd be back where we are
today
do you think this is true or the
reformations that took place unique not
inevitable
and so i think they're inevitable not in
a deterministic way but in the story
will play itself out way
in the sense that you know christ said
christ said he said
there has to be scandal but it doesn't
mean that they're good like it doesn't
mean that their scandals are good
he also says but beware you know
you know don't be the one by which the
scandal comes and so it's like
the the the story of christian it's like
it's like saying that christ
was gonna die and so
it's like it was it was part of the
story
but those that killed them still killed
them it's not it's not like they're
absolved of their
thing you know although christ does say
you know forgive them
but still like they still bear the
responsibility for their actions and so
so christianity has to go through this
um
and and i don't think that traditional
christianity
will be restored to its former status i
don't think that's gonna happen
and i don't think that's what we're
doing it's like i don't feel like that's
what i'm doing
like i'm mostly trying to to plant seeds
i would say um
but i i although i say that okay look so
i say that but
here's russia right so here's here's
russia where
you know it's although they're not the
main although they're not the majority
they're still like the orthodox
christians are still it's like
driving force and culture so who knows
really like seriously i shouldn't say
i shouldn't i shouldn't speak too too
fast
all right so g garcia says marshall
mcluhan talks about a conceptual bias of
the western world
can you elaborate on this
this seems to this i'm not sure like i
don't know like i have to read
what marsha mcluhan says this scene's
related to you and jordan's conversation
personally speaking i think
i understand conceptually this hierarchy
of being you talk about but what does it
mean to get
past mere concepts and so maybe maybe
that's what you mean in the sense that
like i keep talking about how ultimately
these patterns are embodied like they're
not although we talk about them we think
about them
there's a there's a way in which they
have to be embodied they have to be
lived they have to be
engaged in and so it's not just about um
not just about sitting around thinking
about them right ultimately that's why
that's why i say like ultimately you
have to go to church
you have to get involved you can't just
think about it
all right so jan peter yaga says could
you explain the symbolism of the marvel
king legend
of the repose king in orthodoxy do you
mean like the last emperor legend i'm
not sure
i know which legend you're talking about
and you might be talking about the idea
that the last emperor will
kind of awaken at the end or this there
are different
ideas about how for example like the
people who celebrated the liturgy like
kind of walked into the walls and kind
of became part of the walls
there's this whole idea that something
at the when constantinople fell
uh you know that there was this freezing
of something
and that it will awaken in the end you
know
maybe that's what you mean i'm not sure
but this idea of the hidden king or the
king that is
waiting to come back it's obviously a
christian trope like it's the
trope of the return of christ but it's
also the trope in
arthurian legend and and these other
types of legends
and it really is this kind of return to
the king motif that you see in lord of
the rings
so and that's what i think it means if
that's what you're talking about
all right so all right so guys i i think
i'm going to skip a few of your
questions
sometimes your questions are really long
it's just difficult
because i want to get to the to the
questions
so dorothea says could you comment on
the queen of heaven in the book of
jeremiah and her relation
to the mother of god
especially since some of the things the
prophet is condemning sounds like
medieval marrying miracles thanks
um and so the way to understand that is
is is to say something because one of
the things i keep telling you guys about
is that christianity is
ultimately a non-dual thing it's not
christ offers the manner in which things
get saved
and so like if you listen to the if you
listen to the lord of uh spirits podcast
you know they really go into this very
well so there's a sense in which
let's say these hierarchies of gods that
existed that
this is actually what god wanted in the
outset
that god set upon the world these
guardians these
principalities that were there to to in
in like a hierarchy of being
uh supposed to manage at their level
the will of god in the world and so
then those principalities rebelled
against god and tried to take worship
and power for themselves so
it's not it's not it's yes it sounds
abstract and it sounds
uh like just something that's hard to
understand but you can understand it
at a lower level if you want to right
you can understand
that um
that that there's a country with a
certain organization
and that the country the army they have
generals and those generals
are there to manifest the will of the
emperor let's say and to
to to have wars and different different
uh you know to be able to
to manifest the will of the emperor and
the different aspects of
of of the kingdom and then some of those
generals or some of those aristocrats
decide that they're just going to stop
at themselves they're just going to take
it for themselves
and and therefore they start to gather
of money they take
the worship they take the money they
take the things of the people but they
don't
they don't offer up to that which is
above them and they try to be little
gods in themselves
and that's what this is talking about in
terms of
these lower principles that are that are
getting power for themselves but that
aren't participating in the giant
pattern the proper way they're
revolutionary
and so and so the idea would be that
the queen of heaven is still a real
function in the in the world and that
mary plays
that role in a proper way in a way in
which she
says yes to god in a way in which she
offers worship to god
so the icons of the mother of god show
her worshiping
christ the icons of the mother of god
show her praying to god
right she so when you look at an icon of
the mother of god and she's praying
she's praying up and so the image of the
queen of heaven is one which
is giving giving the honor the the
whatever it is that comes to her
offering it up
higher so that's the difference between
the
the divine council which is being re-say
reinstated through the saints and
through our
reigning with christ through our
capacity to rule with him
and the ancient hierarchy of gods but
what's going to happen
is is it's not surprising that you're
going to see that
the the patterns are actually going to
resemble
but but obviously mary if you look at
her story if you look at
images of her if you look at everything
about her
there's nowhere where she keeps that
honor for herself
nowhere she's always offering it up
so you could you could pretend that
that's not what's going on and you could
say oh no yes
it looks like she's offering it up it
looks like
like like she is but no it's all it's
all idolatry but it's not idolatry
because there is this whole movement up
towards
the the the god of creation and so the
the
the honor that we that we give to the
people that manifest god
to us there are they're carried up
into into the highest they don't stop at
them
um it's the best way to understand it so
you will see
the tropes of ancient the titles of
ancient pagan gods
those titles are not necessarily
wrong right so it's like you don't like
the idea of let's say the
the god of the god of war
but you don't have a problem with saint
michael the commander of god's army
those are similar just that one is
subject
is subject and is it and offers his
service and his worship up to
the infinite and the other has a lower
sense in which he can do his own thing
and can kind of
tyrannize the world and right and and
and
make people slaves to his own to his own
passionate
uh structure so
i don't know i hope that's i hope that
helps
i feel like i'm going further in
explaining this stuff to you guys that i
ever have
all right so kent anhar he says hi
jonathan bless it fast
here's something that might interest you
provided you're not already aware the
long standard translation
of the first hermos of the past pascal
canon in the antiogen are
diocese calls pharaoh the persecuting
giant of old
this is a mistranslation from arabic
where the word that should have been
more properly rendered tyrant could also
mean giant yeah
this isn't the case in the greek or
slavonic text but has always felt a bit
uh to me like moses is horns yeah which
you've elsewhere talked about as a
kind of symbolic product productive
mistranslation any thoughts on the
relationship between pharaohs tyrants
and giants
any more examples of symbolically
productive mistranslations you can think
of
that's a great example of what i'm
talking about
because for sure the pharaoh especially
the pharaoh
there's something about egypt which is
connected to this whole idea of
giants in the sense of the the absolute
stranger right and so you can understand
that in the relationships of peoples in
that time the egypt so let's say
egypt really represented this like
ancient like
this ancient non-uh
non-this ancient power that wasn't
submitted to the god of israel and so
it has it really is this kind of
ultimate uh stranger
which is related to the idea of the of
the giant
so that's a great that's a great example
of what i talk about
all right so what time is it 10 37 we're
doing okay
all right so charlie longoria says what
do you think it means that more and more
people are adopting pets rather than
having kids
yeah i saw a bumper sticker saying dog
mom
and another saying i love my granddog oh
man and it creeps me out
especially because i think having kids
was the last thing
attaching people to some sort of
transcendent good parents want
the best future for their kids but i can
see a world coming where people just
want the best for themselves
yeah it's definitely a sign like th this
this sign of the
the sign of the people having pets is
definitely uh
i mean it's fine to have a pet i have a
cat it's it's okay
but it's mostly the problem of of this
kind of uh
you know there's a there's a there's
like a prophecy it's not a prophecy but
there's a description
in uh plato's republic where
they talk about democracy and
it's hilarious because it's they're
basically describing the world
we live in but one of the descriptions
in democracy is that people
end up treating their animals as their
equals
it's like yeah you totally understand
the problem
of gaining legitimacy from that which is
below
uh like what that does like it ends up
it
devolves right it starts to devolve and
then we start to think that
that you know that the animals should
have rights and then the robot should
have rights and then
it's like you're gonna keep going you
know the trees will have rights and then
the grass will have rights and
it's like this weird thing where it just
kind of starts to
to devolve because there's no sense of
there's no sense of normal this normal
hierarchy
then you don't know how authority ends
up working so
yeah it's definitely a sign of the times
that's for sure
all right so josh anderson says hi
jonathan what do you think is the power
behind a movie or modern story
with the meta reality for instance
wizard of oz where dorothy wakes up
to reality with her relatives playing
major parts in the meta reality
the matrix rainier wakes up from the
meta reality
or finally truman show where everyone
else is in on a reality you're not
allowed to be
part of because you're the subject of a
meta reality
i feel as if our culture has a
fascination with these types of plot
devices
and i'm wondering on a symbolic level
what do you think drives the popularity
and admiration these movies often sir
thanks so
i don't think all of these are the same
um
so i'm not sure the truman show is the
same thing as the matrix let's say
in terms of of that notion but yeah yeah
yeah so
i mean i think that the you could say
that what these types of stories do
is that they are talking about the
intuition we have
that there's something missing
like there's something missing in the
world and so it's like what is that
there's that that this sense that
the sense that this world is not enough
and so that's i mean you could say that
that's really
where the religious
all the religious impulse comes from and
kind of condenses into
um and so that's but it's not just about
this representing these layers of
reality let's say like in the matrix but
it's it's
every quest story every story where
you're you
where every mcguffin story right every
every story where people are fighting
over something that they need
something that they're missing if they
could just have that thing then
everything would be okay
so it's like that's just this weird
human condition we have
which is ultimately this desire for the
infinite like it's ultimately
the strength position we're in
as intelligent beings
you know to have this upward movement to
have this movement towards
towards more and so i think that's what
it's about
but the funniest the funniest part of
this the funniest are the simulation
people like the people who who
say that the world is the simulation
it's like i just find that so hilarious
because
what is the simulation of and so it's
like i
completely agree that the world in a way
is is a layers of simulation but it's
not in not in a bad sense but you could
say it's a layered world
of realities that are stacked on each
other
and so that's a traditional way of
understanding it and so you
and so let's say the lower rungs of the
world are heavier and have more
layers on them and as you kind of remove
the layers you have access to more
reality and more light you could say um
and it also
helps you understand or helps you see
the reason for the lower ones
not in a it's like so it's not like a
gnostic sense where you're just
where you are where you're d where the
body is bad or anything but it's mostly
that
it's like as you move up you kind of see
the reason for the lower things
um but it's but the way that people
phrase it it's so
superficial it's like it's so it's so
superficial
so i kind of joke and say like the world
is a simulation
[Music]
it's called language it's just language
is the simulation
in the sense that it's the condensation
or even
concepts or even any form any any
particular making particular ends up
being
what you would call the simulation right
because it's pointing to something which
transcends it but it's also
it's manifesting it in a in a
approximate way
you could say and so that's that feeling
like that feeling we have
that there's something more um
anyways
all right so iliana asks hi jonathan
most of the fictional movies and tv
i like come from all over east asia
things like anime but also movies and
dramas
can you offer any guidance on symbolic
interpretation understanding of story
that emerged from non-western cultures
in general or asian cultures
particularly
and if you happen to have seen heaven's
officials blessing on netflix any
thoughts on that specific show no
it's like i mean i think i told you guys
that i actually don't watch a lot of
stuff
and so i you know once in a while i'll
like watch like i watch one division
then i made a critique about it and so
um so the sense that i have let's say
and so the one theory that i i have been
kind of watching
very slowly is uh his attack on titan
just because the pattern of it the
visuals of it were so
super when when i saw what it was i like
this story is obviously talking about
something very
very much about what i'm talking about
in terms of these this
this wall this uh city with walls and
these giants that are coming in from the
outside that are
trying to attack the city but then it
turns out that it's actually related to
some kind of sin
that you don't know about like i'm not
finished yet but like there's you seem
like there's some kind of sin
that's hidden which is causing the
giants on the outside
and so it's actually pretty it's
actually seeing pretty good and so
like my intuition is that maybe the the
east east asian stories haven't
completely tumbled into like
ideological ideological
blah like just this ideological nonsense
that we're falling into
um so i don't know but
like my daughter's really into anime and
so she she she's really
she really gets a lot from that stuff so
i hope that's what it is but there's a
lot of dark stuff in east asian stuff
too like there's man there's some dark
stuff there too
like i'm not saying they're completely
they've avoided the
depravity of our culture that's for sure
all right so julius bars ditus
sorry julius hey jonathan last month
part of my question was about what an
angel of london would be if the city
were to burn
from your answer it was clear that
principalities and spirit in general can
exist without embodiment
no no no that's not what i said
um so the follow-up are there some ways
for
us bodily beings of conceiving this
unembodied existence and more
importantly the manner that unembodied
interactions occurs
so an example could be maybe the war in
heaven in what way would an angel fight
a demon
if there were no matter for that
interaction to express itself in
uh is this interaction ungraspable for
human beings all the best so
first of all i didn't say that they were
completely un
without body and so
so you could a good way to understand it
what i was trying to explain
is that if the if the angel of london
is still the angel of london if the city
burns
because there is a manner in which
london exists
outside of time you could say in exist
in the totality of all things that exist
and so angels don't have the same they
don't exist in time the same way we do
um and so that's really what i was
trying to get to it's it's not that they
exist
they just exist disembodied when while
the
while the city of london has burned down
but that they
are always the angel of london to the
extent that london has an ex
has a stretch in space and in time that
is that
actually as a hierarchy of manifestation
in the world
that has a limit but then all things
have that and so
anything that angels the only thing that
is infinite is god and so
anything that angels are heads of have
an extension
in space or time and and that's
that's what they're heads of but they
all exist we all
all of this exists in the eternal
reality you know that is that that is
all contained in this eternal reality
that is god and so
anyways i it's hard to talk about this
stuff in a way that is easily
understandable
um so hopefully that that's
that's the that's the best i can do i
guess
um all right so i think
that's it but for some reason it says me
telling me there's two more comments
in patreon but i can't see them
um so sorry guys
if i missed one of your questions
um all right so i've got a few more
questions in
patreon that appeared sorry so keenan
wang asks what do you see as the meaning
of the different points of perspective
in
orthodox art what do you make of the
overlap between this aspect of orthodox
art and cubism
or is there a connection
so there are different interpretations
of that um
i i tend to see it as
the way that i tend to see it is that
it's closer to how you actually
experience
uh reality and this is people are gonna
find that hard to
believe but the thing is that
the idea of representing something in a
static position like the idea of
representing reality
like if you stop and you take a picture
and you think that that's the closest
representation
of reality that's not true
it's that's not how we experience
reality and so
it's like when i experience a building
let's say or i tend i tend in my
experience to want to have the best
vision of something in order to remember
it
and so there's a there's an angle like a
best angle
by which i can where by which i can
experience a building
and remember it knowing that i'm moving
right so it's like i'm
walking in front of a building and i'm
seeing it from different sides as i'm
moving and so then
i have a memory of that building and
that memory will just be in the best
position
of to represent not just the building
but even the different aspects of the
building
and so i think that that's what's going
on in in orthodox art it's like a
compression
a compression of of of an experience
that actually happens in
in in time and in space into one
like into one thing but it's not like
the cubist because the cubist
did it in an abstract way did it in a
kind of uh
pushing it to a level which had nothing
to do with human experience
but whereas i think the way it happens
in icons has more to do with a
with a more embodied representation
of how you you kind of experience these
buildings as you
walk around them and these different
objects and these different things
um and not as this kind of stop in time
and
and try to fix the world in one one
thing
but there are different theories about
that uh there's also this whole theory
about inverse perspective
which i'm not so sure about um
but that's that's like i said that's the
way that i
best understand it is as this
the problem of representing reality in
uh
so for example like a good idea like for
example you'll see in icons and you'll
see in
ancient art this idea that things are
represented bigger
depending on their meaning rather than
their actual distance in space
but but that's also closer to the way we
actually experience reality in the sense
that
if i'm looking in the landscape and
i'm focusing on something like i'm
focusing on one tree in the landscape
if i represent that in a painting
how can i tell you what i'm focusing on
because if i just represented flatly as
this this like picture that i took just
take a picture and there's this tree
but if like if i was focusing on this
one tree i need a way to show you
that that's the important thing in the
image and so making it bigger
is a totally intuitively normal way of
doing that
it's like i'm saying this is the
important thing in the image right
because i'm making it bigger
i'm bringing it closer to you just like
you actually experience that
so when you when you focus on something
you experience it as being closer to you
even if it's further from you in space
you will experience it as being closer
to you
to your experience than other things
that are closer on your
in your perceptual field but that you're
not paying attention to
um so anyway so that's those are the
kind of things that i think are part of
why
they're represented that way but it's
not it's not like a set
thing
so what are your so susan martin asked
what are your favorite movies that have
positive or uplifting symbolism
that are not part of the post-modern
propaganda have you seen films like the
tree of life or the kingdom of heaven
or filmed by tarkovsky and so
i mean i love like we talked about east
asian stuff i love the ghibli movies i
keep
pointing people to that especially if
you have kids all those movies are
wonderful
in terms of uh in terms of
of a powerful storytelling you know i
think for example like the lion king
by disney was just right on i there's
not a lot wrong with the lion king
um in terms of kids movies especially um
i didn't wasn't a big fan of the
of the tree of life to be honest i just
i just struggled to get through that uh
it was so it seemed like disjointed to
me um
tarkovsky movies i think definitely are
dealing with some very powerful things
um i just watched uh nostalgia recently
and it was tough it was hard to get
through because it was it would really
require a lot of attention but it had
some very powerful imagery
in it as well so
and i think like how can i say this i
think like
despite the propaganda let's give you an
example like
so so marvel marvel movies are being
completely invaded by
propaganda but like the story of
of uh tony stark sacrificing himself
using the gauntlet at the end of the
the series that was a great
that was a great move like that was a
great image
of a christian virtue embodied in the
story
and so and so i can still see a lot of
the other crap that's going on
but i can also recognize that there is
there is
nonetheless these little glimmers uh you
know appear
through that so matthew mull brandon
says can we use symbolism for democracy
freedom as in the past a similar way as
religious symbolism that connects to our
meaning
the us the dollar bills are full of
meaning but now
just ornaments
um
i try to totally understand your your
your
your question so let me say this like
one of the things that the us has done
that has uh helped it is
trying to frame their democracy under
god so the idea of putting on the the
dollar bill and god we trust a lot of
people criticize that
because they think oh it's money and
it's stupid to put that there
but i think it's it it are there these
are kind of last-ditch efforts
to to unite the people under the
transcendent
uh a transcendent reality because
i think some people realized
early on or maybe in the past century or
so
that that democracy isn't enough like
democracy can't hold the country
together
and uh and so you need to call upon
something higher so you need something
to unite you
um all right
and so i think that's done for patreon
i'm sorry i might i might miss someone
because i know people
keep posting them
and so i don't i can i can't always get
um
the ones you've just posted all right so
let me go into super chats it's already
11 though man
it's taken up a lot of time but let's
see what's what's in there
where i always forget where those are
yeah
okay there they are i was because
there's two places where they hide them
and so it's like i got them
all right so let's see april hey man
there's a lot of questions guys not sure
i'm gonna get through these let's try
all right so louis for five dollars says
why was adam made from dust why was
eve made from his rib theistic thinking
would suggest god would have made them
both
out of nothing ha interesting well no
they wouldn't and so the idea that god
made adam out of dust is
you you want to understand you know
emergence and you want to understand
consciousness that's what's going on
it's so so god
gathers in all the dust gathers in
multiplicity
that's what you are and that's what you
do multiplicity gets gathered into a
place and then the spirit of god
is blown into man so the the meaning the
spirit
the invisible pattern gets injected into
the gathered dust
and that's what creates man
right and so at a lower level that's how
everything works like that's how reality
works
because we can't we don't create out of
nothing we only god creates out of
nothing we create
out we at a lower level we gather
dust and we we
make we condense it into unity and so we
we can notice the multiplicity and unity
in things and we
participate in that coming together um
so that's why adam is made out of dust
because he
is an image of all of creation in a way
he said he has a condensation of the
bringing together multiplicity into
unity and and then
god asked him to do the same let's say
by naming the animals afterwards
and then why was he made from his rib so
this has to do
there are different ways of
understanding that one is
my favorite way of understanding is
mostly the idea that adam was cut in
half
and that's probably it's like it was
made from his side it's probably the way
that i
best like understanding that so adam
so it says in scripture that god created
them male and female that god created
them
god god made the dust blew
the into the nostrils and and god and
but then in the first version it said
that he created the male male and female
so this like
this ambiguity of how in a way
adam contained both to get at the
beginning
and then was separated into into two
um and that's kind of why it seems like
the church fathers like sangria nissa
for example says things weird things
like
how uh eve was created as a
provision for the fall god having known
that man would fall
is why he was created um
so so yeah but like they're different
saint john chrysostom for example talks
about how
eve was created out of the rib of man to
be to not be subject to him
at the outset but that they would be
equals in
like maybe that adam would have a role
of primacy of origin
but that eve would be as equal in in
in the in the way that they would
interact
so all right so alan tam
five dollars thank you phil cohen ten
dollars obviously became a catechumen
mostly due to your work many years to
you and your family thank you
phil thank you so
devon shane uh for 4.99 so if you watch
the chosen
and if so what are your thoughts advice
for a process inquiring into orthodoxy
so
i wasn't a big fan of that i have to say
i watch it with my family and my my wife
really loved it
and my son loved it my daughter didn't
like it i not i i didn't like it very
much i'm sorry
it's just hard it's just hard to make a
story with jesus as a character you're
just very difficult i'm not saying it's
impossible i'm not saying that but it's
just really hard because
and so i felt like that's i felt like
the chosen was trying
to make christ into uh
just this like happy-go-lucky hipster uh
pastor and it's just not it's not
working
for me sorry all right so
so ulysses k hughes for five euros says
after your last video and your talks on
the divine conduct comedy can you tell
us
some thoughts on milton's paradise lost
i would i would have to i don't think i
could wing that i would definitely have
to i mean i think maybe one day i will
make a video on that i think it's
important
in the sense of i think it plays a role
i talk about it a little bit in the
montero video
i definitely think the image of satan
the way that it's developed in
paradise lost plays a role in modernity
and uh and kind of this understanding of
this heroic promethean uh
devil and so there's definitely that but
i would
i would have to i would have to prepare
myself because it's a big subject
so sorry
um so the abc one two three four five
six
three nine nine for twenty dollars u.s
says the symbolism
of the ultimate angel stretch more
specifically the circle with the three
wings
on them on both sides below the main
angel what so this is the ultimate angel
to draw specifically the circle
with the three wings on them both sides
i don't understand any questions sorry
abc
are you talking about the drawing that i
did like the ultimate angel tetramorph
the
the design and i'm not trying to
understand the question sorry man
all right stephen anderson for eight
dollars uh is there a connection
to masculinity and hunting feminine
being farming how one seeks out
opportunity the other creates
environment i don't think so i don't
think that there's
uh i don't think that there that there's
a relationship between that
um i think that
both in let's say hunting and
in terms of uh farming i think that
there's uh
there's there's both masculine and and
feminine
in both of those so
um so noelle and you could think about
it like
you could think about uh the masculine
and feminine aspect of hunting
be interesting for example you could
think of
abating as a kind of
a more feminine action in the sense of
of seducing or drawing
in or creating a place uh
to attract to kind of attract
things you know to to create an actual
place
and then you know shooting an arrow or
spear or something would be a more
masculine
action so maybe that could make sense
all right so noel tham for 4.99
would you ever consider doing a vid on
the book of enoch yeah definitely
definitely i think especially now with
like all the
all the the lord spirit stuff going on
i'm kind of i'm thinking that that's
gonna happen
at some point it's so funny because i've
been kind of avoiding talking about this
stuff
too explicitly because i felt like
people weren't ready for it and they
would just not understand what it's
talking about
um and you know it's like god has funny
ways sometimes and just like
all of a sudden like the lord's spirits
appear then it's like everybody's just
rushing in and i'm thinking that's
awesome like it's wonderful i'm really
happy for that so yeah
definitely i should probably do that
um so courtney wiley for 49 love your
work
i never see many women in your chats is
it against eastern orthodox teaching for
women to participate in this kind of
discourse
i don't think so i don't think that's
what it's i don't think that's what's
going on
um
i think that i mean like i've
i think that i would need to i don't
know why it's hard to
totally explain i guess
i would say it's like there is okay so
i think that it's it's normal this is
gonna sound weird to a lot of people
like
i'm not a priest like i'm not an
official person i think it's inevitable
that
men should want to talk to men more
than talk to women and women should in
general want to talk to women more
just out of like a weird healthy thing
about relationships
and so i am always very like for example
give an example like i'm always very
cautious
like i almost never will have
uh like dinner or a coffee
with a woman alone uh
unless it's like a very old lady like
something like it's very clear
but but i'm very like i'm super careful
about that stuff
and so it might be boiling out in my
behavior online it's possible and i'm
sorry if that's what's happening
um but i did i have had some
conversations with uh
with some people and i'm and there's a
video with um
with dr paula boddington which is coming
out uh
which is coming out soon um
uh uh on ai again and on the ethics of
uh she's also she's in
she's an expert on the ethics of ai but
also on
the ethics of uh kind of biological
uh medical bio stuff and so
there's a video coming out in the next
few weeks on that so that'll be that'll
be fine so
so that might be what it is i'm not sure
i don't totally it's like
i actually just got to move organically
and just invite people and people that
come on my horizon
i invite i don't have a system really
hmm you guys are having me like trying
to understand my own behavior here
all right so process rowell for five
dollars says hey jonathan big fan of
your videos
i wanted to get your opinion of orthodox
theologian david hart
i don't think that's i i don't i don't
i'm not going to answer that question
i'm sorry
process i don't want to answer if you
have a question about specific things
that he said i will answer that question
but i'm not going to answer an opinion
on him
that's that that's not a good idea i
think all right so
uh don you go teeth
ninety for i think it's australian mad
mason bradford for ten dollars
australian i think in terms of symbolism
is there a relationship between a train
and a serpent
hmm interesting um
i don't think so i've never thought
about it i've never thought about that
i'd have to think about it because it's
slithers i guess because it
it it's flexible maybe
i have to think about that
all right so james schwartz for five
dollars
how might someone send you a piece of
digital art and would it be possible to
hear your initial initial reaction
live like this um it's always possible
to send me
stuff on email you can find my email on
my carving website
i don't kind of advertise it just
outright but you can find it if you're
looking for it
whether or not i'm going to answer just
really depends on what i'm going through
sometimes i get 20 messages a day of
people
kind of trying to get my attention for
something and so because of that i've
actually tended not to
answer people not not because i don't
want to just because if i do
i end up spending my whole day in front
of the computer which i already
end up doing despite that and so and i
need to like i need to carve and so
i would say like in the past month i
haven't carved a lot because there's
especially since the jordan peterson
interview
there's been so many things that require
my like attention and answer to and
and uh and so it's difficult but if you
send me something that's awesome
like that's totally awesome i'll answer
uh you know it doesn't mean that if it's
good i i
it doesn't mean that if i don't answer
it's bad but it but if it's if it's like
astoundingly awesome then i'll probably
answer
so you can you can give it a try
um rich gray can you help me with
christopher's in the old testament
i don't know how to answer that it's a
very vague question
i mean the sense that that there are
images in the old testament
which seem to point to the incarnation
um and so i i would say that that's it
so like
different images that you know like
let's say the i'm trying to go like
right now my mind is drawing a blank
it's like the
old testament is full of them um
so for example like the image of uh like
okay the image of the ancient of days
with the son of man
and so it's like that's a that's an
image of christ that is kind of
starting to appear um and so there are
different versions of that
all right so david furtado says for five
b
r l i know what that is when reading the
bible should we use the meaning of the
words
had back then or use today's meanings of
the words
um i mean i think you need to
to use as much as possible the
try to get the meaning of the word and
the the old meanings of the words but
ultimately you hope that the fathers and
the saints and the translators and all
these people have been able to
transmit these in a way that is relevant
today and so it's not just a weird
desire to be accurate because that
doesn't usually doesn't give much
so chandler turner 5 usd most of those
my age mid-20s who don't
outright reject religion there's a
strong draw towards perennialism
what is the argument against it
i would say the easiest argument against
perennialism is that it
it it ends up acting as a weird pseudo
religion like it ends up acting as
something which stands above religion
and then people can
can can think that they're superior to
religion in the
in their perennial position and so it
ends up acting like a
like a weird prideful um
kind of idea that i
that i can i can judge the other
religions and that's what you end up
seeing with perennialists is that they
they're often like saying well this is
this is good here this is bad here this
is
and they they kind of have this strange
think they have this strange capacity to
stand above everything
and to and to judge it and i think that
that's
deadly for the soul you know i don't
it's not a it's not a real path it's
just like a
weird abstraction so
so that's what i would say the main
argument at least that i have against it
so david cosiar for 1144 cid do you have
any thoughts on narcissism and why god
would be calling out asking where adam
is in the garden could this be a
demiurge the false god speaking
since it's not omniscient thanks
so this is really this is actually a
really important question uh
in the sense that
everything that god does in scripture
everything that god
says every way that you see god in
scripture is a condescension
and so the idea that god
acts out in the world in a way that
humans can understand
it doesn't mean that it's a demiurge or
a false god
it just means that god
since god is the source of all reality
then god manifests himself
at the level of reality that is
appropriate to
whatever god is is wherever god is
appearing in the world
and so we don't we can't see these
gestures or the fact that god appears as
as a as an angel or that god appears
in the the burning bush or that god
appears in these different things
or as the glory of god that descends in
the temple we can't see that as
a limiting of god but rather just
let's say the just god revealing himself
at the level where he's revealing
himself and then pointing ultimately to
something would transcend
some sense that that manifestation
um so anyways that's that's the way i
understand it it's the best way i
understand it
um
uh so the villain report for 49.99
um hello jonathan i saw you speak on the
issue of the resurrection being literal
but you laughed at the question and
seemed to be
unconcerned with it do you believe it's
literal
sorry i'm laughing again villain report
how is that knowledge found thank you
for your unique perspective
uh
i don't know what that word means the
word literal
like you mean that you okay so if you
mean that you'll be resurrected
with the same body it's the same
in the same um
at the same with all the same uh
limitations and characteristics that you
have now then
no that's not what the resurrection is
obviously not
the resurrection is obviously more
than just this body that i can it's more
and so that but the resurrection is real
it's not just a metaphor it's not just a
it's not just a
and so and so if you when you read
what's the way that saint paul talks
about
spiritual bodies
i don't totally know what that
completely means i can have
inklings of it i can have intuitions of
it i can trust saint paul enough
i can trust christ enough to understand
what that's kind of pointing to but i
don't completely
see it i can i can understand the story
enough
to trust that nothing is lost how
say it that way that if the world is
non-dual if
if reality
if reality exists then there's a manner
in which it exists in the totality of
existence and that
totality has its own reality
and that includes bodies and then
it includes body but i don't totally i
can't
completely see it i have intuitions of
it
and so i think that anybody who thinks
that the resurrection just means
that just means that whatever i look at
in the mirror like the saggy
thing that i look this hairy saggy thing
that i look at when i
when i'm looking at myself naked in the
mirror it's like
if that's not what the resurrection is
i'm sorry to tell you
it's like that that's not at all with
there's nothing
let's say the the the transfigured
christ that appears
to to the in the gospel seems to be an
image
of the resurrected body the ascending
christ who ascends
into heaven seems to be an image of
the resurrected body and there there are
moments in the tradition for example uh
saint seraphim of sarov
manifests shows to
his inquirer what the resurrected body
is
is or what it would it and and what he
manifests
is like pure flame and that's what the
person sees and so it's like there's
the resurrected body is not a it's not
an obvious thing it's not a it's not as
it's something you understand in the
story but you'll understand
you can't understand in its reality
until you experience it
and so i haven't experienced the
resurrection
all right i recall you saying uh so john
lefeve says i recall you saying you
listen to kanye
jesus walks have you listened to
kendrick lamar's good kid
mad city he's steeping christian
symbolism and would love to hear your
take
so it's funny because i saw who was it i
saw talk about that recently someone was
talked about that on twitter um
and uh i was sitting and i started it
was weird because i i i was i was an
idiot i wasn't thinking
i was sitting at the table and uh i was
with my daughter
and and someone said oh this this vid
this
album has like christian symbolism and
i'd love to hear your take
so i'm like okay so i was drawing with
her and so i like i put it on which was
like the stupidest thing
that i could have done so i put it on
and like after one minute i'm like okay
let's turn this off because i'm sitting
here with my 13 year old daughter
um and so no i didn't finish listening
to it so i mean i guess i'll listen to
it at some point i don't know
i just thought it was extremely it
started off let's say rather
rather craft and crude which i'm not
like i understand i'm not a
not a prude or anything but uh but uh
i'll listen
to it on my own time at some other point
so carlos vargas for 49. hey jonathan
more news on god's dog it's coming
it's coming um it's coming
but i i don't have it i don't have a
definite date
um
all right um patrick morrison for ten
dollars usd [ __ ] wishes jonathan thank
you
that laura person 9.99 did you happen to
see
the kanye and the sunday service choir
perform at dmx's memorial service
interestingly
kanye has been wearing a black veil at
recent public events i have not
followed that no like i i really i
haven't followed
let's say i haven't followed uh kanye's
recent things
i know that he's getting a divorce and
everything
you have to be careful a little bit
because like sometimes i feel like maybe
uh how can i say this like i said watch
the fools and just be careful
like i didn't say follow the fools or
you know
uh so you know yeah i think there's
still
there's still some things that are going
to come out of kanye but uh
all right so guillen para for 6.99
canadian
asked me a question in french quebec
because everybody i would say 98
of the people watching this so he says
quebec seems to be in
a grave spiritual state
even existential state is their hope
i often have difficulty finding some and
let me say this to you is that i have i
have a similar
thought and i think you've if you've
followed me you know that i have this
kind of
despair regarding quebec and the
french-speaking
canada but quebec has a way of moving in
uh block like it has a weird tendency to
kind of
shift in uh everybody kind of shifts at
the same time
and so there might be a shift on the
horizon who knows you know
all we can do is plant seeds and i've
started like this is something that
you know as cobit kind of winds down i'm
gonna be
emphasizing uh some more local stuff
french stuff i started the french
podcast with uh jp marxo
if you go on my french channel jonathan
you will find uh we've already done i
think like five episodes of our podcast
in french and i'm gonna start to be more
present in french speaking world so
hopefully it'll help me be more
connected to french canadians
um at least and hopefully we can plant
some seeds
for something
um so christian stander asked hi
jonathan please can you explain how god
is at the same time the essence
similar to the chair of the cup and also
a personified entity we talked to
um so god is a is is is not
it's three persons that's important to
understand uh
and so god is infinite
god i mean god is not is is is is
the infinite it's not the same as the
chair um
so it's not completely it's not
something that i can answer
i'm not good at this also at that kind
of question
and then running out of steam as well
all right so the new guy
it's like 11 30. you guys are keeping me
up it's crazy
all right so the new guy for 499 are
there examples of words saints in the
christian tradition and if so does one
stand out to you
any who were literal historical figures
uh for sure
yeah i mean i mean for sure like uh
there's definitely st george who is kind
of like the
ultimate warrior saint but there are
other were saying saint dimitrios
saint uh mercurius um there are plenty
of them
and uh and some of them were
historical figures for sure
um
so the villain report goes back and says
did christ actually resurrect in reality
in the same way that i
breakfast this morning in reality did it
really happen
i want to believe but i don't want to
lie to get there
and so read the scripture okay what's
what's written in scripture is what
happened
so if if that helps you it's like yes
christ did resurrect in reality
and and it's not exactly in the same way
that you ate breakfast or the banality
of your eating breakfast
in this morning it's not the same way
because it it doesn't have the same
effect on reality
that eating your breakfast in this
morning had it just doesn't i
can't i'm sorry to read the story and
look at what happens
look at how the disciples don't
recognize them and then
all of a sudden they recognize him look
at how christ appears in the room
you know with all the doors closed look
at how look at how
uh he ascends into heaven he's standing
there with the disciples then he
vanishes up and then these two angels
are there
it's like that's not how you ate your
breakfast this morning i don't know
what happens when you eat your breakfast
but that stuff doesn't happen when i eat
my breakfast and so
and so yes it definitely happened uh
but it's not at the same level as your
breakfast so i don't know
how else to answer you my friend um
so yeah
all right i think we're done i think
we're done some of these
keep coming in i see symbolic memes
is symbolic means deserves that i that i
look at his
question so symbolic means for five
dollars says how can perennialism
become a religion if you're vacant's
religion that's not a religion clearly
states
it's not a religion with the cringe face
you're getting getting into trouble with
uh with uh with my friend there
so yeah exactly all right guys
so thanks for thanks for your thanks for
your time guys i'm going to
um i'm gonna go i'm gonna go and so
thanks for your attention everybody
this has been the longest q a i think
that i've uh that i've ever done
and so thanks for thanks for attention
thanks to brad
and to jacob and to lisa who were there
doing all the the dirty work of uh
of uh working on all your comments and
so
i i really appreciate it i will see you
guys next month
there's uh there's uh this month's
patreon only video
is gonna come out i hope before the end
of the month i'm really working with
thomas from the storytellers channels to
get it edited actually
it's gonna be a video on the why the
inverted pentagram is considered satanic
and so i'm gonna since i did that
montero video
i decided i'm gonna add one more little
thing to that which is
helping people understand why this
particular image has kind of
crystallized as a satanic image
and why that's a coherent coherent uh
thing that happened and so everybody
thanks for attention and i will see you
next month
bye-bye